okay so this is where we started right
yeah and the reason why i knew
something was going to be up is just
because of the one
the one is what throws everything off
okay which which means
you've got to do something with the left
hand side to break it apart and
something solvable
because factorizing the left hand side
will get you nowhere you can make it
nice and factorized and then you still
have one there so it's like oh crap
okay um you could put like cos squared
plus sine squared on the right hand side
but then you still end up with problems
because you've got a car is in there now
right so you can't make the right hand
side zero it doesn't work
now just to rehearse it you know the
trick we had before
making this like so
only works when you're adding and
subtracting two because then
the conjugates will cancel okay so since
i can't do that
that's my clue that okay i'm gonna have
to use triple angle now i'll just remind
you
you don't need to know triple angle so i
would not expect a question like this
unless part a were you know expand
and then they um you know gave some
marks on it
if they wanted to they'd have to do
something like this and it's the same
with integration
like they can ask you to integrate
something you've never seen before
okay classic example is this guy
so you know after i give you this
example you will have seen it before
but the point is that it's not a form
you recognize like it's not a standard
form it's not on the table of standard
integrals which you'll start getting
from all your exams from now on
but if this is part b i can give you a
part a
which will lead into part b okay which
is which that is from memory that's
that's the way it works okay
so if you can use this then they can
give you whatever
right and since triple angle is not in
the syllabus the program
they have to do something like this okay
and then
okay
after after this after you guys are done
with revising tree okay
all right so quickly let's just let's do
the expansion let's do the expansion
okay so i'm thinking of this as sine of
2x plus
x yeah okay so this is the sine a plus b
so what's the extension sine a
cos b plus cos
a sine b okay
all right now that looks terrible but
because of these two you're going to get
squares and things are going to cancel
with each other
so what's this that's two sine cos right
two cosines are going to become constant
squared
okay this one i should go straight to
the form which is just in terms of sines
which is do you remember
um
yeah good why not okay now i could
expand that all out but since i see a
common factor of sine
this will make things a little easier
for me so what have i got here i've got
two times cos squared which is actually
that's 1 minus sine squared
so i'm going to write that like so
is that okay so that's this then what do
i have here
plus 1 minus 2 sine
squared okay so there's a three
and that's a minus four okay so
if i expand everything i'm doing i'm
trying to hurry through it right but
you're going to get this if you go
through all of the lines
okay all right now let's bring that and
take it over here
so this is two times that
uh times sign again equals one
okay now the reason why i knew this was
going to work out well for us is
you've got one side here three signs
here when you multiply three
you'll get two and four so this is an
equation reducible to a quadratic
okay which is why i thought okay i might
as well keep on showing you how to do
this so i'm gonna get
six sine squared
minus eight sine to the four
and i'll bring the one over okay
let's do a substitution here so i'll let
u equal
sine squared okay and i'll try
i'll make this positive as well so this
is eight u squared minus
six u plus
plus plus right so now i saw
so what's this equal to actually i
didn't even think of this before
we can factorize this quite easily can't
we a pair of numbers that multiply
to positive eight and multiply by
minus four minus two that should work so
this is eight u minus four
eight minus two divide by eight
okay so four go through here and two
will go through here
so this will become sorry that's a 2.
2 u minus 1. i divided that by 4. i'll
divide this by
dividing yeah divide this by 2 now
okay there we go right so u is equal to
a quarter
so what that's going to mean is when i
take square roots of both sides i'm
going to get positive
and negatives
sorry plus or minus plus or minus
good now the plus or minus is like oh
that's terrible right there's so many
but that's actually really good because
that means when you take your four
quadrants
because you've got plus or minus you
just take all the quotients right
because
i can take all of them right so if i
take this one the base angle is pi over
four
right so pi and four in the first
quadrant is prime four
in the next quadrant it's
pi minus time four which is three pi on
four
in the next one it's pi plus pi and four
um here it's going to be two pi
minus one four which is seven
pi on four and then i do these guys
right now the base angle this is
pi on six right so i re has a pi
on six uh five pi on six
seven pi on six and eleven pi on
six now i actually i was a bit silly i
didn't check what the domain is
i only solved it for um not the two pi
if they gave you a different domain
for instance if they gave you say minus
pi to pi
right instead of going forward uh
i would just get plus or minus of these
because that means you're going forward
and you're also
backwards okay uh it's the same it's
just a different way of thinking
but so what do we do we do triple angle
if this is part b they'd be like hence
so i do my substitution and then you get
this reduce between quadratic
and it looks terrible but if you stay
with it it's not that bad
thanks that's right